[Music]
what's up y'all as
always welcome to the channel so we're
jumping back into our examination of the
Adventist Jesus today if you haven't
seen the previous Parts especially part
four I highly suggest checking that out
first the link to the full playlist is
in the description box down below so
question for you when did Christ begin
his priesthood that's the question in
Focus today and it's more important than
you might realize part of the SDA
Church's fundamental beliefs
specifically that of the investigative
judgment in the sanctuary is the claim
that at Jesus's Ascension he was
inaugurated as a high priest where he
would then begin the work of a high
priest in a sanctuary building in heaven
they call this the second phase of his
atoning ministry for those of you that
are regulars this will probably come as
no shock but it is ultimately coming
down from the Adventist inspired pen
where in the great controversy on page
420 she
writes such was the service performed
unto the example and Shadow of heavenly
things and what was done in type in the
min ministration of the Earthly
Sanctuary is done in reality in the
ministration of the Heavenly Sanctuary
after his Ascension Our Savior began his
work as our high priest says Paul Christ
has not entered into holy places made
with hands which are the figures of the
true but into heaven itself now to
appear in the presence of God for us
Hebrews 9:24 so very clearly they teach
that Jesus began the work of a high
priest at his Ascension the
million-dollar question is is that what
scripture teaches Mrs White tried
supporting this by citing Hebrews 9:24
which is rather ironic considering 9924
is an expounding upon 8 1-2 which they
love to site to say Jesus entered into a
building like what was on Earth yet 924
actually shows that the most holy place
is heaven itself not a compartment in a
building that's in heaven nevertheless
Hebrews 9:24 doesn't say anything about
the high Priestly work of Christ
starting at his Ascension had Ellen
started back toward the beginning of the
book and tracked with the author she
would have caught what we were told back
in Chapter 2 specifically verses 10-1 17
it
says for it was fitting that he for whom
and by whom all things exist in bringing
many sons to Glory should make the
founder of their salvation perfect
through suffering for He Who sanctifies
and those who are Sanctified all have
one source that is why he is not ashamed
to call them brothers saying I will tell
of your name to my brothers in the midst
of the congregation I will sing your
praise and again I will put my trust in
him and again behold I am the children
God has given me since therefore the
children sharing Flesh and Blood he
himself likewise partook of the same
things that through death he might
destroy the one who has the power of
death that is the devil and deliver all
those who through fear of death were
subject to lifelong slavery for surely
it is not angels that he helps but he
helps The Offspring of Abraham therefore
he had to be made like his brothers in
every respect so that he might become a
merciful and faithful high priest in the
service of God to make propitiation for
the sins of the people so continuing
with this theme from chapter 1 which is
telling us about the Majesty of Jesus
the author explains that he came in the
likeness of human flesh which is why
it's fitting that he was referred to
prophetically as our brother and that by
his incarnating in suffering which would
include his gospel work of Life Death
burial and Resurrection he's able to be
the founder of salvation but did you
catch what he said in verses 16 and 17
after telling us that Jesus's work was
not on behalf of angels but humans we
were told that by his incarnating he was
able to become a merciful and faithful
high priest in the service of God to
make propitiation for the sins of the
people so another question for you where
does the bible tell us that propitiation
took place in Romans 3:25 as well as
elsewhere we we read that propitiation
occurred when Jesus was put forth as a
propitiatory sacrifice at Calvary it was
this act of God putting Christ forth
that showed God to be both the just and
the justifier as it pertains to sin this
is why John tells us in his first
epistle that the love of God was
demonstrated not by us loving God but in
him sending his son to be the
propitiation for our sins the word
propitiation in Greek is helion
interestingly enough it's translated as
Mercy Seat in Hebrews 9:5 that's because
the mercy seat was sprinkled with the
blood of the atonement which is where
propitiation took place since the author
of Hebrews told us that Jesus would
function as a merciful and faithful high
priest in his work of propitiation and
that work took place before he ascended
that means that Jesus was functioning as
a high priest before his Ascension
further evidence of this is in Jesus's
wearing of linen garments on the day of
atonement just like the levitical priest
did John's gospel in particular gives
much attention to Jesus's burial clothes
notice what information he includes he
tells us in chapter 19 that the Roman
soldiers divided his garments into four
parts all but his seamless tunic then he
tells us that Nicodemus brought roughly
100 PBS of myrr and allows to spice
Jesus's body which was bound in linen
wrappings then in chapter 20 we find
that his body and his head were wrapped
separately when he was raised from the
dead the linen garments and face wrap
were left in the Tomb so between the
seamless garment M and allows and linen
wrappings is something of significance
being told to us after all it's only
John the last of the gospels to be
written that tells us these details and
why is that because it all speaks to to
Jesus as the great high priest in Exodus
28:39 we're told that Aaron wore
garments of glory and Beauty when he
carried out his Priestly work and among
these was a tunic that was checkered of
fine linen and it being checkered would
imply that it was seamless in Leviticus
16 we're told that on the day of
atonement however Aaron would set aside
those glorious garments and he wore only
holy garments consisting of linen tunics
undergarments Sash and turban when the
work of atonement was complete he would
then put back on his garments of glory
and Beauty the linen garments that Jesus
Jesus was wrapped in speak to his work
as the great high priest on the true day
of atonement they were left behind in a
holy place when his work was finished
and he assumed his glorified body we see
the place of the linen garments being a
holy place by the fact that John
wouldn't enter the tomb Before Peter
even the details about what Nicodemus
brought to the tomb speak to the
Priestly work of Christ notice for
example what Psalm 45 6-8 says this is a
Messianic Psalm prophesying about Jesus
who would take his throne after his
passion it
says your throne oh God is forever and
ever the scepter of your kingdom is a
scepter of uprightness you have loved
righteousness and hated wickedness
therefore God your God has appointed you
with the oil of gladness beyond your
companions your robes are all fragrant
with myrr and allows and Casia so if
you're familiar with the book of Hebrews
you'll recall that the author quoted
Psalm 456 in Hebrews 1:8 when he said
your throne oh God is forever and ever
referring to Jesus but then the Suter
says he was anointed with oil of
gladness his robes are all fragrant with
myrr and alows this is precisely what
Nicodemus spiced Jesus's body with and
myrr in particular is the first spice
mentioned as what scented the oil that
was used to anoint the high priest and
the Tabernacle in Exodus 30:23 now there
are a number of other connections that
we could look at but all of that to say
none of these things are arbitrary the
holy spirit is telling us so much
through all these various details that
are quite easy to read over and not make
the connections the point being Jesus
functioned as a high priest well before
his Ascension the Ascension was his
inauguration as king of kings and Lord
of lords not high priest when he
ascended back to the father he sat down
on his throne after accomplishing the
Redemption of all things which is why
the author of Hebrews cites Psalm 46 and
110 and tells us repeatedly that Jesus
is seated ruling and reigning forever
and ever the Adventist Jesus is not
ruling and reigning right now how do we
know this in the March 14 1846 issue of
the day star Ellen White recalling her
supposed First Vision said
this about 4 months since I had a vision
of events all in the future and I saw
the time of trouble such as never was
Jesus told me it was the time of Jacob's
trouble and that we should be delivered
out of it by the voice of God just
before we entered it we all received the
Seal of the Living God then I saw the
Four Angels cease to hold the Four Winds
and I saw famine pestilence and sword
Nation Rose against nation and the whole
world was in confusion then we cried to
God for deliverance day and night till
we began to hear the bells on Jesus's
garment and I saw Jesus rise up in the
holiest and as he came out we heard the
tinkling of bells and knew our high
priest was was coming out then we heard
the voice of God which shook the heavens
and earth and gave the 144,000 the day
and hour of Jesus's coming then the
saints were free United and full of the
glory of God for he had turned their
captivity and I saw a flaming Cloud come
where Jesus stood and he laid off his
Priestly garment and put on his kingly
robe took his place on the cloud which
carried him to the east where it first
appeared to the Saints on earth a small
black cloud which was the sign of the
son of man while the cloud was passing
from the holiest to the east which took
a number of days the synagogue of Satan
worshiped at the Saints feet so if you
recall back in part 4 we looked at this
with regards to her supposedly seeing
Jesus in heaven wearing the levitical
priesthood garments even though they
were unique to the Levites but did you
notice what she said about the changing
of that attire she claims that Jesus
showed her that at a point in the future
after the close of the investigative
judgment he is going to remove his
Priestly garments and assume his kingly
robe it's long been the defense of many
Adventist apologists due to the likes of
Adventist Scholars like Roy gain that
Jesus didn't literally change apartments
in 1844 it was just symbolic of a change
in function meaning there was no literal
move from a holy Place Apartment into a
new one well the same has often been
said with regards to the garments issue
they claim she wasn't saying Jesus is
literally wearing levitical priesthood
garments it's only representative of His
function as a priest well here we have
the inspired pen telling us that after
the close of the investigative judgment
Jesus will assume kingly attire which
means he'll transition from functioning
as a high priest to a King at that point
this is why they also hold to the
erroneous concept that Believers will
have to one day stand before God without
an intercessor because Jesus will cease
that function and start a new one had
Mrs White read Hebrews 6 and 7 more
carefully before getting to chapter 9
she would have seen that Jesus is after
the order of melchisedek and mkis DEC
was not only a high priest but a king
this is why Jesus's Priestly work of
mediation doesn't take place from a
standing position such as it did with
the Levites it takes place from his
Throne where he is seated showing that
the work is finished Jesus Christ is a
high priest king and the work he is
doing now he will do Forever This is why
the author of Hebrews also tells us that
Jesus forever lives to make intercession
for his people as long as he rules and
Reigns which Revelation tells us is
forever and ever he will forever
function as he does right now as
mediator king of kings and Lord of lords
if Jesus's mediation were to cease man
would be eternally lost even into
eternity Jesus Will Remain the
intercessor connection point between God
and man forever Bridging the Gap keeping
his people eternally secure the
Adventist Church does not have a Jesus
that is ruling and reigning presently
they do not have a Jesus that is
functioning simultaneously as a priest
and King he is still standing dealing
with sin functioning like a levitical
priest in a building in heaven and will
become a king at a later point in the
future furthermore they don't believe
propitiation took place at the cross
which was the true day of atonement so
they failed to see that Christ was
functioning as a high priest in his life
death burial and Resurrection for his
people it was in that work that Jesus
was dealing with sin which is precisely
what the work of the priest entailed as
all of these details begin to add up we
see that the Jesus of adventism is a
very different figure than the one of
both history and scripture when you have
a Jesus that didn't deal with sin as the
great high priest by way of his life
death burial and Resurrection you're
talking about a false Christ if you're
an Adventist we want to encourage you to
examine these things in hopes that
you'll come to know the true Christ and
his
gospel hey thanks for watch watching if
you like content like this and you want
to partner with us access more resources
or just learn more about what we're
doing visit answering adventism tocom as
always until next time God
[Music]
bless